[Music]
are you running a lot of Apache spark or
Hadoop workloads on Google cloud data
proc there are several ways to monitor
Hadoop and Spark applications
in this video we will see how to
configure a persistent history server to
monitor the spark applications I am Anu
I am a strategic Cloud engineer at
Google let's get started in this video
you will learn what is persistent
history server how to set up a persisted
history server and some of the best
practices of setting up a persistent
history server
what is data proc dataproc is a fully
managed cluster platform for running Big
Data Frameworks like Apache Hadoop
Apache spark and various Big Data open
source tools and Frameworks to process
and analyze vast amounts of data let's
take spark workloads how can you run
your existing spark workloads on data
proc with dataproc you can run your
spark workloads on dataproc serverless
long-running data proc on Google compute
engine or Google kubernetes engine
clusters or ephemeral dataproc clusters
what is data prox serverless with
dataproc serverless you can run spark
batch workloads without having the
provision manage the cluster and the
service with an ephemeral cluster life
of the cluster is tightly spark job what
do I mean by that you create a cluster
configure it to run specific spark jobs
and delete the cluster
you can use dataprop workflow templates
or Cloud composer to orchestrate this
these clusters can be benchmarked sized
based upon the spark jobs these jobs
scoped ephemeral clusters or effective
for batch processing the challenge with
ephemeral clusters and dataproc
serverless for spark is that you will
lose the application blocks when the
cluster missions are deleted persistent
history server enables access to the
completed Hadoop and Spark application
logs for the jobs executed on ephemeral
clusters or serverless path persistent
history server is stateless and it
constructs the spark UA of the
applications by reading the applications
even blogs from the Google Cloud Storage
bucket let us see how to configure a
persistent history server
one you need to create the persistent
history server Google Cloud Storage
bucket in advance
Step 2 configure the logging directory
property when creating ephemeral
clusters or serverless path jobs this is
the directory in the persistent history
server GCS bucket to store the event
logs so far we have a persistent history
server Google Cloud Storage pack it
created and configured the Clusters to
write the logs to that bucket
step 3 create a standalone cluster and
configure it to read the event logs from
the persisted history server GCS packet
Standalone cluster constructs the spark
UI of the applications by reading the
event logs from the Google Cloud Storage
bucket
this is a persistent history server
now it's demo time we will see a demo of
setting up a persistent history server
let's navigate to the Google Cloud shell
in the console This Cloud shell provides
command line access I have created a
Google Cloud Storage packet to store
event logs from ephemeral clusters
that step is not included in the demo
this gcloud command creates a persistent
history server
you will find the details of the code in
the description of the video
now the cluster creation is in progress
this command basically configures the
cluster to access this spark and
mapreduce job history files and yarn
aggregation logs from Google Cloud
Storage bucket now the cluster is
created
the public documentation has all the
details on how to configure this
the link is in description section I
highly recommend you refer to that while
setting up
if we check the configuration and click
show properties
it shows mapreduce job history directly
and Spark event log directory
then directory intermediate directory
and event log directory
these directories are used by persistent
history server to construct the map
reduce unspark UI from the logs
now you can access the map history
server UI on spark history server UI by
navigating to the web interfaces section
now we will see how to configure
ephemeral cluster to write the logs to
Google Cloud Storage button
this gcloud command
creates an ephemeral cluster and
configures it to write the logs to the
same GCS bucket that the persistent
history server is accessing
this cluster creation is in progress
now the cluster is created
we can submit the sample spark job to
the ephemeral cluster
I am going to test whether spark scalar
job
in the main class I am passing the main
method of the Scala application
this is a spark Pi program it calculates
the rough value for pi using an
approximation method
[Music]
I can pass the corresponding jot files
I am setting the argument to be thousand
which indicates the number of job tasks
now I click submit
job is submitted to the ephemeral
cluster
and this job writes the event logs to
this persistent history server GCS
bucket
[Music]
the running application you can access
the yarn UI by navigating to the web
interface section of the ephemeral
dataproc cluster
[Music]
the status of the job is completed
so now we can navigate to the spark
history server of the AP metal cluster
and this shows the spark by application
details
if we click on the app ID
it shows that there are thousand tasks
which is the argument we passed
so we can navigate to the spark UI of
the history server instance
and this presents the application
details on corresponding event logs of
the jobs run on ephemeral cluster
if we click on the app ID
it shows the stage level task level
details
this is how you set up a persistent
history server to Monitor and analyze
all the completed applications
now we will see some of the best
practices of setting up persistent
history server best practice one start
with a single persistent history server
for a gcp project is optimal if there
are multiple applications running and if
you want to isolate and monitor specific
business applications you can create two
or more persistent history server GCS
buckets then create two or more
persistent history servers pointing to
the corresponding GCS buckets in a
project
best practice tool in the event of a
zonal or Regional failure you can
quickly create a new persistent history
server in another region pointing to the
same persistent history server GCS
packet best practice 3 we recommend you
Benchmark with your existing spark
applications in the testing environment
before promoting the persistent history
server the production in production
monitor the instance for memory and CPU
utilization
in case of performance degradation in
the spark UI you can recreate the
persistent history server with increased
Mission size with higher memory
best breakfast food by default the spark
demand memory is 3.8 GB if many users
are trying to access the spark UI and
dig into the job application details or
if there are long-running spark jobs
with many tasks like 50 000 or 100 000
the 3.8 GB heat size could be too small
this might impact the spark UI
performance in such scenarios try
increasing the heat size to 8 GB or 16
GB
best practice pipe configure a 30-day
lifecycle policy in persistent history
server GCS bucket to periodically clean
up the event logs this will improve the
performance of the persistent history
server UI
in this video we saw what persistent
history server is how to configure a
persistent history server and some of
the best practices persistent history
server is important for troubleshooting
issues and engaging Google Cloud
technical support to troubleshoot and
explore you can also use the logs to
optimize the performance
there are various other scenarios to
consider when setting up a persistent
history server I am sure this video sets
the foundation to get started to stay on
top of all the latest changes
periodically review dataproc release
notes this helps you adopt new features
and functionalities if you are
interested in exploring more about
dataproc or the history server please
check out the description section in
this video
thank you for your time thank you for
watching